Speaker 1: You know, we suspected for a
while that when many of these right wingers
say abortion is murder, they don't really mean
that. It's something they say if it's convenient,
if it helps them raise money. Now, of course, some
of them sincerely mean it and I mean the voters.
But when you look at the polls, you see that
support for abortion being legal in most cases has
increased over the last 50 years quite steadily.
And so intuitively, there have to be some shills
out there who are only claiming to have these
positions about abortion to the extent that it's
useful to them politically, but they don't really
care about it that much. Donald Trump is a really
great example. The whole Herschel Walker scandal,
as it's being called, wherein despite claiming
to be pro-life, despite claiming that abortion is
murder, no exceptions for rape, incest or the life
of the mother. Despite saying all of those things,
he now has been credibly accused with receipts of
urging and paying one of his ex-girlfriends to get
an abortion, paying for one of his ex-girlfriends
to get an abortion. So, of course, the Republicans
will now denounce Herschel Walker. Right. We
cannot support a man who. No, it's not happening.
It turns out apparently they don't really
care about abortion being murder. Here's Dana
Loesch Lash, who says quite straightforwardly,
she's a right wing radio host. I don't care
if Herschel Walker paid to abort endangered
baby eagles. I want control of the Senate.
Speaker 2: So does this change anything?
I mean, do you want my opinion or you're
listening? Yeah. Not a damn thing.
Speaker 1: Oh.
Speaker 2: How
many times have I said four very important
words. These forwards. Winning is a virtue.
Speaker 1: Oh.
Speaker 2: What I'm about to say is in.
No means a contradiction, okay.
Or a compromise of a principle.
Speaker 1: So in other words, it is that.
Speaker 2: And please keep in mind that I am
concerned about one thing and one thing
only at this point. So I don't care if
Herschel Walker paid to abort endangered
baby eagles. I want control of the Senate.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2:
If The Daily Beast story is true. You're telling
me Walker used his money to reportedly pay
some skank for an abortion? And Warnock wants
to use all of our moneys to pay a whole bunch
of skanks for abortions.
Speaker 1:
So the big takeaway here is a lot of these people
don't really think abortion is murder. Or they do,
but they're willing to vote for the murderers
anyway if it's politically convenient. Republicans
think abortion is murder, except when the
Senate is on the line. Here's Don Lemon
on CNN last night speaking to right wing,
you know, whatever, right wing strategist,
right wing analyst, consultant Alice
Stewart. And this is just unbelievable.
Speaker 3: The whole position here, because the
entire time that we have been on the air together,
you said that the reason that you held your
nose and voted for Donald Trump was because
of his stance on abortion. Right. And now
you're saying it doesn't matter that that
Herschel Walker is hypocritical about an
abortion and allegedly has paid for one.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: An abortion that it is now okay
because of inflation. So now what is it?
Speaker 1: Listen, guys, abortion is murder,
but have you seen these gas prices?
Speaker 2: What I'm saying right now,
if I were back in my home state of Georgia and I
had to decide between a candidate like Herschel
Walker who may or may not have paid for one
abortion, or Raphael Warnock, who is supportive
of taxpayer funded abortions for everyone. I think
that the choice is very simple. Herschel Walker's
policies are more in line with Republicans and
conservatives in the state of Georgia. And moving
forward, this is going to be a tremendous.
Speaker 3: How do you know he's telling
you the truth about those issues
if he's not telling you the truth
about abortion?
Speaker 2:
We'll just have to take his word for it. Right.
Speaker 1: Well, you took his word about the
abortion thing, right? Wow. Wow. And then
rounding this out is Newt Gingrich, who
talks about how Walker's deeply committed to
Christ and also has had many concussions. So
I guess it's okay what he did. I don't know.
Speaker 4: I talked to Herschel about this this
morning and I've known Herschel. Good. Wow.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, if you've known him for
a long time, then certainly, please proceed.
Speaker 4: I think he's a remarkable person. I
think he's the most important Senate candidate
in the country because he'll do more to change
the Senate just by the sheer presence, by his
conference, by his deep commitment to Christ.
Right. The degree to which he is you know,
he's been through a long, tough period. He
had a lot of concussions coming out of football.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, you can't blame the guy
who says abortion is murder for paying for an
abortion. He could be concussed for all we know.
That's Newt Gingrich's take. These people are
completely pathetic. These people are hypocrites.
These people. So I tweeted about this and there's
kind of there's really two possibilities here.
One, they do believe abortion is murder. They
really do. They just don't care about voting
for so-called murderers as long as it keeps a
Democrat out of office. That's one possibility.
The second possibility is they don't really
believe abortion is murder. It's just something
that they say when it's convenient in order to
raise money. And it is becoming extremely obvious
the more that this Herschel Walker thing goes.
Let's now talk about the polling in that race